gang unexpected livestream gang holy
[ __ ] I'm tired gang surprised I'm here
alright no more gang [ __ ] jokes guys
get started on the game in a second I
have a busy day today and I don't have
time to play in the afternoon or evening
some I thought I'd just do it now but
god dammit my tire I did not sleep much
last night it was hot edie care was
annoying
Maya was annoying everyone was annoying
this is one of those nights
and here I am early yeah and it shows I
cannot hide the fact that I'm tired it's
not happening let's get into the game
surprise livestream [ __ ] yo what
time is it for you guys what time is it
for you guys ok I think I slept like 4
hours let's get into the game everyone
is in a different time that's crazy
we're a different world I have were in
the cinema we had our Lowell
all right we're playing blasts of us I
remember now
snip-snip time did I practice I feel
like I should it's part of the game
right give it a go
also I can clearly for once just play
whatever I want
[Music]
that's kind of cool
[Laughter]
I'm tired
drive streaming ah I guess well that's
how everyone got so annoyed with me
making my own songs just play what it
says Felix I'm like Jesus Christ some of
you get very easily annoyed I'm not
gonna lie
all right let's find Dina or Dion now or
banana whatever her name is I want to
make so many jokes about the situation
but I don't want to be inappropriate and
I don't want to get in trouble and it's
really hard for me I hope you understand
how hard this is for me where the [ __ ]
was she I don't remember yep no she
wasn't upstairs it's morning now I see
this [ __ ] you think I'm the bad boy you
look right now pretty hot
how'd you fix it it was a loose
connection antenna they found our mess
at the school good
this guy Owen he went AWOL
what is able to Tony out to him maybe
what about her
nothing yet so the numbers are locations
the TV station we were at that's six
there's a lot of chatter coming out of
to so I'm assuming that's their home
base just have the baby already come on
get it over it stop complaining
that helps how old are they supposed to
be last night was stupid first time a
little bit of chemistry between them
I'll take no trespasser Tommy where's 14
not a hundred percent sure okay I think
yes hmm
if this is 712 all the way over here
I guess it's somewhere in this
neighborhood
well crest
okay I know it doesn't seem like it I'm
really excited to play
I'm just very tight it's hitting me you
know you know take a seat yeah not good
hey I'll go get him
you keep tracking them okay
yeah okay
wait give me your hand
it's for good luck I don't believe in
luck I do
it's interesting how I could be wrong I
could be completely wrong but when you
explain Locke to a lot of Japanese
people they don't understand it like we
have this thing in Sweden where you're
supposed to hold your thumbs to wish
someone luck but that's just a foreign
concept for them they would say do your
best which is such a better attitude in
my opinion gum buddy up okay instead of
just leaving it to chance please but
they must have some understanding of it
I just I don't know they usually don't
say good luck that's just not a thing oh
thank god no dianna all right that's
nice see this I would have preferred not
gonna lie someone made a really funny
comment cuz I I couldn't explain why I
thought it was so cringy when they
started calling each other babe out of
nowhere it's like they had sex after
smoking weed once hey babe it's gone
babe yeah I feel like I read some
comments too and people were like why
are you playing the game too you're not
enjoying that I am enjoying it but I
also feel like I want to play it to see
if it's good or not so many different
opinions about the game I've read some
other valid comments about killing off
the main character and someone said oh
in movie sequels they always do that
they kill off the main character to make
a sequel and they did in godfather or
something like that and those are
classics I think it said something like
that but I'm like [ __ ] this isn't a
movie and we waited seven years for this
game we had there was expectations and
the whole the whole dynamic of the game
just get changed it becomes like oh I
guess that happened I hope in 10 hours
or something it the game gets good now
it's a bit different than a movie yeah
that's how I feel about it all right
looking around the ban on this news
you got something squirrel
should we snag the squirrel I'll leave
the chat to the sign it's not the
squirrel yes or no hit him right between
that I've obviously not
I'm always he's not gonna do that
you [ __ ] psychopath I enjoyed the
gameplay
I'm the scenery
still a lot these [ __ ] hold on Tommy
I was thinking about another thing can
they just have like kidnap Joel wouldn't
that have been better you think you
still done there understand they don't
want to do the same thing and then you
could have more flashback of how la Joel
teaches le different things right oh how
she got so good at fighting and stuff
those could be flashbacks then again why
would they kidnap Joe a lot of them and
then maybe they could have had it so low
you could fail so you'd want to actually
do good so you can save Joel but that
was a bad ending maybe like in heavy
rain you can mess up and the kid dies
that led to so much tension and you
wanting to succeed in the game it just
feels like all right I guess that's how
it is like the death in the in the
beginning didn't really inspire any big
motivation I think they'd like it you
see what I mean
all right we're not being critical I'm
just giving my opinion doesn't mean I
don't enjoy it
I'll just be quiet the whole time I'm
sorry you know what I'll just play the
game okay this is that the same place
see this is why uh sure just to be quiet
and play the game there we go
hey guys it's me
let's blare 24 I love this game I love
it to death I love every aspect of it I
am
that's kind of rude calling Ellie
affected I'm not killing dogs oh god
they spent me
I hate these small groups I'm wearing my
headphones backwards this is very
confusing here let's find him get back
on
[ __ ] dog don't write me out man [ __ ]
[Music]
dog by Edgar I'm not sure I'm not
shooting the dog I'm not sure good damn
it [ __ ] you game I'm done I'm [ __ ]
done
sorry my headphones are backward and
that's very confusing
that went pretty well goddamn I suck
I'm sorry dog I'm sorry Jesus Christ I'm
sorry yeah I'm so I'm sorry about that
bro I'm sorry [ __ ]
sorry a-hole they're so sad about the
dogs dying the [ __ ] is wrong with you
I'm so sorry
[Music]
[ __ ] you make me kill dogs for oh my god
there's more we're alright
anymore M&L I was like where are they
throw a grenade yeah I never used to
grinning oh there we go let's take them
out stuff this time I don't need to save
ammo so we can't cross the
is it literally just this guy like lower
gang
looking for life oh this guy's clueless
I'm a snake
I'm a snake in the grass what you doing
that boy what you doing up there I'm a
snake in the grass
how to sleep and feel like 10 out of 10
question mark James journalist must have
been like you shoot dogs ten at a time
okay all right let's look around for
loot we've got some blood I keep calling
alcohol blood good cause it's a fake we
got some more blood
there were sivanna in the game they'd
probably make me shoot in I wish there
was no Stefan I'm hating this game all
right well we had the shoddy I was like
no I'll Drive to the [ __ ] game stuff
you can only make one at a time okay
what if I attach one does I make it so
that I can still crack one no score for
shot
we didn't really check in here I have to
spend so much time looking for supplies
but I was it break down there as to
break down there and break over here and
a break over day and then break in there
we checked there already
all right let's keep going unless I made
something important Sunday morning
laughs me [ __ ] that's good I am
really glad I'm streaming this it's a
lot of fun having you guys here
especially spamming [ __ ] sake I'll
take it back
[ __ ] off all of you stop spamming chain
it's a weird that I would have preferred
if it was just le uh I guess I can't
understand to some people the hole that
she's lifespan is a bit I don't know
where but maybe people didn't play the
DLC cuz it was revealed in there that
she was and it was really cute
actually I really like the DLC I don't
think it's that much out of nowhere I
just I'm not feeling the chemistry that
much we'd be on a yet or Dinah I think
that's what it's missing cuz it could
have been a cool thing I'm sure he gets
more now that she's pregnant you know
Ellie will have to step up now that
she's the father you know I mean they
all day so make me shoot me more dogs
that's all I ask
don't walk in swore at a some bolts and
[ __ ]
so I need this to get up somewhere at
least Rome ow
le push I seem get up there right
swish swish swish swish swish swish
swish swish swish there's an uphill
though it doesn't feel right whoo oh I
hope so weird
she's like right before jumping out
right a bike shot can make another bomb
[ __ ] it's this kind of trap mines
exploded when enemies get near them oh
cool I love that I don't really have
much to upgrade maybe pity
oh I read another funny coming it was
something along the line like this game
feels like you're giving a kitten and
then you're told that kitten is terminal
look it up that's what this game feels
like hey blood here alright so we can
cry a lot of [ __ ] so these new bombs are
I like that that's fun let's crack those
[ __ ] let's see we have 45 can you
upgrade anything yeah faster crafting
alright rather say for movement speed
while prone
goldstar liquor let's go inside the
batter had alcohol in here yeah
strawberry ice cream delicious hey they
have alcohol in the Ellen shop I like
that and yeah I guess that makes sense
that's freeload where we got in the
fridge a chocolate bar whoa
I have a as a bloater isn't it that
might be a good time to try out these
new minds so how do these work think I
pissed them off
[Music]
no [ __ ] that's not what I wanted to do
let's try it out guess it then die how
ironic
it's died from its greatest strength
alright that was about two something
make another silence or now so a gun
nerds pointed out it it's true you can
make a silencer like that but there's no
such thing as a silencer it's called the
suppressor Felix I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry hey hey hey we make another one
what is the tape used for its upgrade
ease check can't all right
that I miss loop that maybe you're
referencing what I forgot when I was in
the building
I gotta say the bloaters are a nice
addition but they're also a bit
uninspired they feel straight out of
left 4 dead 2 what should we call them
boomers no no we can't call the boomers
[ __ ] a idiot they're bloaters Oh God
not at a kid center oh no what happened
here something happened here
hey it's Joe Rogan wow did you know you
can eat and help oh sweet another one
all right
aim stability increase hundred percent
oh [ __ ] yeah I'll take that I look
forward to getting the bow and arrow
actually smashed it for no reason it's a
comfy game to play
come get me [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
a zombie isn't it I only see that one
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay there's more than one it's like a
good chance just take this one out since
she so graciously came and David
god
you go inside
yeah
whoa that's a mistake here on the
texture do you see it it's kind of
floating above worst game unplayable now
oh he doesn't like it either what you
crying about
little boy why are you so sad say I the
uragan [ __ ] is Lord of the
underworld whoa this place look nice
let's get that mmm big here oh yeah an
actual tattoo shop let's get a butt
tattoo commemorate Joel let's get it
you know how to lowers be with her all
right yo that was one more shop I miss
well look at those stairs so cool
yes I'm impressed by stairs it's the
bike shop all right we're good sheep
how do I get to those stairs I don't
know prolly through here
I will grab that rope I will grab that
soil you never know I will grab that cat
I'm missing out on somebody to lose
Allen yes the best would be is just not
kill this guy Oh God I didn't murder I
just murdered his friend its best friend
in the whole wide world no don't grab
that like that Oh God
30 82 65 remind me
so there's a safe somewhere they Wharf
killing the bloater and find the safe
safe good oh nice
let's see what the note says yeah I
could always go around him sorry head
over your notes again yo when dad comes
back as go say walk over to the garage
so it's in the garage
alright let's check the garage
[ __ ] it why not
quiet boy plus we didn't check here
either any of you we're in the hair
salon
what a nice neighborhood they got hair
dryers scissors Oh conscious [ __ ] that I
can't pick up where's the garage excuse
me oh that's a lot of them in there oh
it small a tough time maybe mine hmm if
I move this this is gonna pull down and
then we're gonna come out I don't know
what the best
let's have what should I have already
talked I don't know maybe stun
I'll share with the best course of
action
Molotov yeah
oh that alerted some minute oh [ __ ]
[Music]
Isis one guy
there's a Boomer isn't it they don't
know how to open doors right of course I
don't remember this safe iswe too early
for my brain I like how I'm scrolling up
the chat instead of just [ __ ]
checking my notes I said Jose that be
yet wrote it for me thank you if you're
trolling me you're dead
just you understand penis snip-snip
sorry
no for [ __ ] sake you're really wrong
you [ __ ] cut off his dig oh my god he
wrote it wrong oh it's snipping time
course a I'm sorry man
you [ __ ] up
my memory is so bad trying to learn a
different language and it's taking up
every part of my brain all right that
was definitely worth it
hell yeah oh yeah I got a quiver isn't
it
now let's find the bow gamers I was a
long gone though okay never mind
so many people say I skip out on stuff
in the game I don't know what the [ __ ]
they mean God we're so full of stuff
you got the small gun holster in there
really maybe you didn't find the other
one earlier and that's why you got the
small one that's kind of cool
so now we can switch very quickly
between them that's cool and now we can
misplace all right so we got the Boomer
out didn't we
let's just walk around him I don't want
to mess with it but I'll be ready if
[ __ ] hits the fan I don't know where he
is
I hear him oh cool
just be quick here then no wait
I like to sneak around him bye bye fatty
Oh he mad Oh
oh my god I missed so many pills there
can't wait to get the bow and arrow
that's exciting
we're close to it does that mean we can
upgrade yeah
[Music]
I'll [ __ ] I promise you know a crate is
a same traps as you have Thank You
Leonardo
I don't read donations but I read them
do you know what I mean
whoa hope you did that Tommy oh oh no I
heard the dogs I'm not done with the
dogs man
Oh God a ton of them dead end you could
say that again fix the machete I don't
know how to do that oh hello
[Music]
oh god I have a present that was cool
[ __ ] rest in peace machete s sucks
I like how I was complaining how the
backpack was open this whole time but
clearly it had a purpose for the arrows
to stick out it's kind of funny
oh yeah at least I don't kill dogs I
feel fine neighborhood crime watch
alright please slow down
you guys Oh No
look at this poor Teddy he's stood no
chance machine gun in here
I had a nice outdoor grill oh they had a
[ __ ] jacuzzi
let's go gamers always peeing nice I'll
have the Sun ready now ok [ __ ] hits the
fan your land I'm sorry I won't be able
to keep taking care of Alfie [ __ ] out
thee I'm sorry
Boris are you Yolanda is worries sorry
about Alfie don't like him anymore you
can have him
as a salt sale now that's a nice what is
that what is it were they sailing
sailing yeah English oh there's coffee
Joe love coffee nice I just need an ally
more than a Newton Bing bong bong Bing
bong I want only this guys [ __ ] crazy
I can't yeah that reload
le doesn't do good in stress that's my
bad I should reload before comment yeah
cool forget the bow nice can I reload my
[ __ ] gun hey
so that's a different type of zombie
morning learning in a gang
Edgar sir how are you doing boy
notice a team that is like oh we get
some practice with nabobs mannequins
let's try our hardest you know I brought
it breaks the arrow hold okay that's
more like oh wait okay so they break if
you miss your target all right what 11
is leg you can sometimes recover your
arrow from a headshot so go for
headshots is not their same sweet make a
bow suppressor you guys are smart one
give you guys enough credit go prone
[ __ ] dogs just find them so we're close
to Tommy all right someone goes in there
and one goes in here
Kanna feel like we should take care of
the doggies first
but I'm honestly not sure what the best
course of action is yeah look going in
here seems good Edgar do not look at
this I don't want you to look at this
daddy's about to do something he doesn't
want to do that's more people out here
in the yard
yeah all right this will be a good one
to take out you're in for a surprise
you're in for a little surprise
oh the dog caught up my scent forgot
about [ __ ] oh god that was quick
let's get the [ __ ] out
[Music]
we're this is stressful Oh God
dog do not rat me out
[Music]
ready the danke what I didn't they're
lying
[ __ ] they know exactly where I am okay
so you can't escape nice
[Music]
knowing okay
reload gang Oh God looks like spooning
me I can craft em oh oh oh for [ __ ]
sake I had more ammo
Oh what is she holding a [ __ ] Club
she says asking to get murder isn't she
she's in the Grahams I know sorry about
your club bro and the craft Samara I
should have done this before oh I should
save some nevermind maybe now it's a
good time to go back since and they are
what are you thinking
one in the house
oh he's coming out there dog
she took Casey out I didn't push her out
Oh God dogs here [ __ ] they'll never find
me hi dog all right dog you don't have
to go we don't have to do I'm sorry
they just had to add dogs to the game
that it no that can't be
can you guys come here I'll throw a
break all right
guess we'll check it out
okay there all along this
going down sir that bombs are insane
dude [ __ ] already gone bear bear there's
way more over here
let's go come on
there's so many squads getting pulled
into one trespass oh geez Louise they
smelled me already smell you later game
another [ __ ] dog Jesus Louise don't
take any chances
okay this is better
so this guy has got something smells
something girl how do I deal with the
dogs sorry about that bro they're
confused self gang
come on
look at this ohdid cheese yeah I don't
know she's hiding it's impossible to
find me why is the air so dumb
sometimes I guess I should take out the
dog through the air that's right that
would make more sense you coming in yeah
come come
yeah
the bottom area is clear
sir - thank you thank you
sorry thank you Oh Mike again can i crap
the health pack I didn't even do
anything
you doing okay all right definitely
got this game just evolved into computer
kiosks I was doing so well it's all out
I don't know everybody's ruined because
every year no hi Patti I buy hay they go
sweet Jim here
oh my god [ __ ] game game stop alright
I'll take what I have or I can get at
this point
good time to reload
that's my help switch to the other gun
long gun
well aren't you then
I'm innocent that's what bothers me
about this
that was alcohol before [ __ ]
No
[Music]
I'm not surrounded what the [ __ ] are
they smoking
yes
it's a chase scene yeah I feel like I
did not hit the Bible that what the hell
are you doing here oh [ __ ] that's
unexpected let you do this on your own
Jesse where's Dina she's safe she's just
sick what kind of sick I expected like
Claire out each area on each one that's
clearly not where you're supposed to do
Christ there's a lot of them is he our
new partner he how hurt are you you okay
your friends out there rushed me no
warning no nothing we expected Tommy but
that is odd
give me [ __ ] about it later [ __ ] you
know that right I got stressed out okay
we all have bad days that's for planner
we need to get some distance
I'll redeem it now watch me I'm really
not ready I would I would prefer to look
for some supplies but you know trespass
preaching to the choir man maybe try
that house yeah oh I got this one are
you [ __ ] kidding
[Music]
hey remember when I said I'll redeem
myself he got him he got him he's better
shot than I am
first forward lads
why can't get back why do they let me
stop Joe okay get it okay give me one
second life hey that was pretty south
hundred Ocean
golly I'll aim is so ugly
God hasn't started
I'm trying to shoot that it's awkward
[Applause]
then still thank you
now you today night you did
[ __ ] crazy
don't get Jessica
got it
chewing now
[Applause]
this bad
[ __ ] rollercoaster hell yeah
[Music]
god I'm so annoyed I [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] that I love it now man we get a
second change but that's a pretty view
well it is what it is
[Music]
swimming with all those guns
yeah Minot I got another hour
Deana oh yeah remember her okay nothing
will sell hands that's cheating
we should get inside yeah Ellie by
question mark how'd you get past marina
Matt sneak out
friends problems with my problems I
heard you say oh it's just a stomach
thing just say your prayer oh yeah
that's that's his baby isn't it just say
you're pregnant you don't need to do
this I'll shut up
so would you leave Jackson day after you
there's bad snowing I crossed into
Oregon I've been doing 80 now stretches
for the past two weeks trying to catch
he's jealous oh now I'm not streaming
tonight I'm streaming this morning
because of it that's cool part though oh
yes Joel please huh are you with me oh
god damn it good anyway this silent
treatment
man I mean I forget my own birthday if
she didn't remind me when it was you
should just apologize to her I just sit
okay
what's going on damn nothing why I can
tell when you're off yeah it's got some
stuff on my mind you let me know if you
want to talk about okay got stragglers
how many you got a sniper mount whoa I
could do that I could definitely do that
might give it a whirl yes look at this
told you watching my shirt
I'm feeling generous
see that sign there red one yeah try
hitting that no way to draw them out of
wherever there oh there's a problem
I forgot leave the bullet room to drop
and I see there you go
Wow sounds attracting them we are on
patrol that's clear mouth wipe them out
can you guys send still for a second
just like one moment which one is
standing still most there you go gotcha
I like this thing that's all of them
oh yeah usually more over this way you
want to keep [ __ ]
this [ __ ] gun is amazing where are
they coming from boards like to move
through this area in winter they always
end up leaving behind a few stragglers
they do the same routes every here like
a migration for something what's that
about well when the barometric pressure
reaches a certain is there more oh yeah
check out the shed looks like they're
moving downhill
look up by the truck they're munching on
that deer there guess they're hungry Oh
see if we can get a head shot wait time
looks clear
well he's in cries you hear something by
the ski lifts look under those gondolas
by that Tower
see well that's far how far how high
should we aim try this hi can you guys
stand still just take your time
yeah but they're moving they're cheating
hi Oh should I go for yeah I think you
see I wish it was a zombie apocalypse I
could just do this
imagine how fun that would be Oh too
long my bad I'm trying
stop moving on now he's still oh yeah
well done I'm not seeing any more girls
good man yeah me neither
all right let's head in see if Joel's
back sure so those weren't zombies what
do you mean
aren't y'all a bunch of smarty pants I
bet you've you played you'd be crying
y'all be over it's so scary boys on TV
sure that's ladies first
I can't hear them it's too far away I'm
supposed to say anything
jeez I'm doing everything 100% echo is
the ow see that [ __ ]
did I miss a shot you don't talk to him
he's gonna think something yeah gets
Megan back to him well you have to do
more than hi and bye I love you
don't keep playing the game don't make
my mistake the [ __ ] is this
that was y'all shooting up there right
oh just some stragglers Ella got to try
out my scope doll
thanks like it yeah feels good
I see you've even got around changing
the string yet I didn't know I was
supposed to yeah we'll get you some new
ones where's that music store down there
I bet they got guitar stuff I mean that
Ares long overdue for a sweep anyway yes
I'll keep watch
hey kiddo I say hell yeah sure and
that's our cue wanna say something are
you sure you don't want to come get on
now he's waiting can I get your gun it's
way cooler okay let's go all right
Oh me kiddo yeah again bag so you had
told me cross anything when you was out
just a few we saw from the ridge you oh
you know found two runners in a house
Jessie tells me you're handling your own
quite well on the group Patrol is even
recommending you for paired controller
oh I think you're still a bit young for
it
I'm a better shot than almost all of
them and I have more experience than
most of the new repeat I am a better
shine do you think you're ready
dad trust okay thanks you just do me a
favor and start with the shorter routes
for now you know see how you handle them
all right if you guys became a zombie
what type of zombie would you be
remember those savage starlight comic
books oh you're in to be honest yeah
Tommy and I found some when we were
moving through that school the other day
did you like him
dr. daniela starmie she's pretty she's a
savage well what she does the captain
Ryan and that kiss match yeah I mean he
definitely deserved it but there's a
nice shimmer don't get into trouble yeah
hey bot see there's a music store this
is the game I wanted yeah I see it
first thing I got it I'm good I'm good
homie uh I don't think we can go this
way right there sir that him swim across
this okay so now what cutting through
that hotel I'm up for it
hell yeah damn it
Joel we'll get it you think you can fit
in there that's worth a shot
kara below yep Oh God hold on
I'll grab this and I'll grab that
I got dude someone took the TV in that
room welcome to my mainest MTV you're
just too skinny need to eat more welcome
excuse me
it's the ad pocalypse hey an Iranian boy
I might come useful I grabbed this I
grabbed a I grabbed it I grabbed dad I
grabbed this place is giving me the
creeps
I think I see the way through but we got
spores but you masks oh how do I need my
man I have to it's just us what if we
run into someone okay fine
now joel is over so careful that was
like his character trait to always take
the step beyond and then he just says
his name for no reason I guess it was
Tommy that said the name wasn't it you
gotta be smart about this yeah you tell
me you ain't told nobody
Eddie Jesse Dina
you ever been in here before
no you just patrol the streets been like
a bit of an oversight now baby I'm oh
I'll take it the gas powers
I wonder the sports smells like you know
said I'm madly weapon oh you got a plane
supplies here I bet they're smelling
roses
we got in here Joel they got a lot of
ironing boards in this place the world
it's a hotel in here I'm sure one of us
people went missing from Jackson them
teenagers from last year this was too
old
that'll do you Tate's forget the last of
us this were IRL edition joel is alive
can you imagine that was so happy I got
you Horace I moved back home
okay you're missing your head boy
this is the gang my one oh my god yes
yes you see excuse yes okay let's make
sure we use these and don't forget to
reload Joel they got coffee you love
coffee hey another Mellie nice
[Music]
[Applause]
yes good old Joel and Ellie bonding get
it I think so
thanks bro you say we give up on those
strings for the day
good I said it better myself give up on
the strings No
that's another one all right let's go
through what do we got it looks like it
might be something following you
Joel is carrying me I like it
oh this is spooky and through the wall
question mark
[Music]
I'm gonna [ __ ] die [ __ ] die
[ __ ] dangerous it's a tank
damn toe damn [ __ ] you guys thought I
was dead but it was a scripted event
[ __ ] I never die zero deaths told
douche case you're new we haven't died a
single time this episode it's been
insane headshot headshot headshot doing
nothing so not asleep oh shake off I
want to get out of here thirty years old
and still suck at games feels bad man
all right do it do it
see that's the zombie I want to be if I
become a zombie
you know me not some [ __ ] I know I'm
ready to go pro did last of us have
multiplayer a lot of Uncharted game save
the loader didn't they say before I
never seen those zombies before when we
saw bloaters for the first time spores
are clear
it's mostly to fight back there huh yeah
Jesse and Deanna are gonna lose their
[ __ ] when they hear about the ironic to
see him slow during a gym them alright
good date right on and off why no Jesse
and I are just friends
right I see hey Joel can you spot me I'm
actually gonna do leg day after this
livestream good old gent leg day yeah I
don't have legs though why would I do it
cuz you don't skip out on leg day no
matter what how's my health so it's not
Paul right now and there's a medkit
there does it make sense to keel grab
this and the answer is yes okay
I love you baby baby hey imagine if you
start watching the live stream now and
be like oh that's so cool
last of us to with Joel I love it might
check out this game this game looks
pretty cool you're playing with that
Joel like I expected that's so cool
Aloha divided it is the fact that you
all died some people are so angry about
it - they're like yeah main characters
yeah I can I'm doing a listen before I
go in rooms but it doesn't seem to
matter yeah okay yes there's got to be
more fighting
dude no legs man that's one of ours
isn't it Thanks hey Joel yeah cuz it's
got the junior right I think it's them
a couple I ran away last year yep I
think you're right Jackson is a
wonderful place but we got tired of
hearing the stories of people suffering
everywhere else we wanted to save lives
we had good intentions we didn't make it
an hour before running into a horde
now we're bitten we've decided we're
gonna end our lives instead of turning
well one of the you didn't tell our
family and friends that were sorry with
Adam in Sydney well one of them I shot
her I can't take my own life I'm a
[ __ ] coward Adam you want the [ __ ]
Adam what though you bought me if you
die in a flashback you die in real life
[ __ ] it's let's go get Tommy and we can
get these bodies back to Jackson got 30
but we took me out of the Firefly
hospital you said there were dozens of
people like me
uh-oh yeah uh-oh yes with the Tommy
hurry you're a bad liar Joe I've never
met another immune person before have
you
I could be hiding it yeah like you are
do ya do you believe that
yeah he's now really the time for this
yeah believe it we traveled across the
entire country to bring me to the
fireflies I had so many questions for
them yeah and they just died you pulled
me out of there while I was still
unconscious because I let them run their
tests and when I saw that they were
useless I got as ahead of me how do you
know they were useless maybe if you just
would have given them more time they
could have figured something out they
were gonna kill you there was no cure
there's nothing that could help these
people are anybody else I know you wish
things were different I wish things were
different but they ain't
wash your hands never it's all good get
these kids back to their families
they're still messy like to rehash
you know
could come on
[ __ ] coward Adam too
[Music]
how come zombie Adam didn't eat the body
of the wife that would be my greatest
reason to just end it oh that's a Greek
symbol on the bracelet isn't it I
remember seeing that it is he's passed
out hey let me do that oh now we're back
to the game huh okay
he's a good guy
why didn't you tell him wasn't the right
time that one no I was a good time
what about this anything worthwhile
actually yeah
Abby you know this girl
Nora her unit was a sign of this
hospital they were collecting supplies
or something this hospital yeah
but you're gonna go now yeah we have a
lead like at least just wait for Jesse
to rest up she could be gone by then
heli
we know her location maybe Tommy does
too
what it's weird seeing her all grown up
especially the contrast can you come
help me with the door please
[Music]
right if I follow route 5
I should take me to the hospital all
right
we're back in action baby let's make
first sure everything is reloaded my
brick is reloaded my health packs
reloaded ok we're good all around five
track down Norah get her to tell me
where Abby is easy we have a lot of
arrows and that's about it this this I
need this I need
bow and arrow time nearly kill we go
need to go came to go push I reloaded my
bow and arrow the morning guys
so that's let's go from here on on I
mean term beginning gonna climb up here
hey 7-eleven go through here
maybe you can make a silencer now I want
a silencer I want some snacks some
Scooby Snacks Foxboro remember that
brain I wish you did the anime way where
they just call them Le balloon or
something
now we're missing alcohol and a canister
in the arm yes best item in the game
still missing canisters and tape spooky
[Music]
fauna yesterday apparently that spook or
spooky is a racial term so you're not
supposed to say it anymore
Halloween is canceled guys excuse me
Jesus it's poufy okay for the P yeah I
can't take spooky away okay progress
thanks Ellie yeah
breaking the fourth wall
this is comfy I like this mom is in here
yeah I almost broke the glass it's our
way in without breaking the glass this
is just that one asked you
[Applause]
ice cream that's a good time to practice
well they go through their window how oh
wait I can do that how do I counsel
a lot of these [ __ ] let's get the hunt
there come on little boy nice
kilts get their hopes coming back [ __ ]
stray in there let's not turn this into
a [ __ ] show
come on come on over here boy
[Music]
a double I got too many blankets man
this is an issue for me oh god another
this is the spot to be apparently it's
one more is that it damn it
why you cussing for
yes no I meant no yeah yes yes yes yes
yes yes
Sharon Arana list of the deserters it
was so fun
Android the migas
interesting it's a nice place let's hit
the arrow back Thank You loot loot loot
loot Lu got all the [ __ ] in this [ __ ]
let's check that why don't we go give me
something good in the kitchen
hey a lot of pills sweet so no
can we leave and all the members guys
appreciate you let's keep going
early livestream what time is it it's
got to be either really late or really
early supplies here
Edgar's so tired so cute
here I'm sorry
oh it's so cozy there's one of each
don't have ammo for it though
going in here tonight the night I got
farted I take back everything I said
go here nice you gotta break a window
all good
got some tape do it is that a plus F
$200 plasma TV that's a magazine sisters
we can use that need more tape
scooby-dooby October 13 a cat 30 years
anniversary evacuate all right my bad I
meant to click on the bottle
hey we got to say sweet no combination
now see if we can find it
I feel like they recycled the comment
well there are some improvements for
example when you go down on your when
you get shot and you lay down that's
kind of cool and then we got some more
mines and chin and he clearly works like
it's just a recycled from uncharted
really without the epic climbing and Sun
they still filled with supplies
hey that a little vegetable garden okay
so looking for the safe code what do you
guys reckon we should upgrade we can
upgrade the
[Music]
I don't [ __ ] around [ __ ] I know
you're out there
[Music]
gotcha [ __ ] let me crash Jesus [ __ ]
people yeah do you have the safe code
anyone of you now yeah where was I
yes replace a grip decrease weigh draw
speed
knocking speed what's knocking
can't afford shy save up
upgrade my peepee
draw speed that is did anything change
finally some ammo for this one god edgar
you staying
dude your smelly dog not gonna lie
oh here's the code isn't it no wait this
is a chemistry huh interesting we get
more explosive I crafted arrows with
explosive tips oh hell yeah
not even doubting ass dude this as well
cuz then we can improve our Mali's nice
oh they give us a lot of pills yeah she
[ __ ] knowing that she saved cold yeah
yes I'm never gonna never know it and
her a real loaded gun again after that
Fiasco man here we go leaving the house
we're moving stole the others remember
really wish is there back of this
they got a lot of plasma TVs in here
rich gang
I like how they captured Ellie twice
they've had so many chances to kill
outside went in here again
but the first up and they know they have
to kill her be more careful but they
still let her go I don't get it
maybe there's a reason why reveal later
all right maybe the patient's safe code
isn't nope
look at the calendar okay oh of course
their anniversary wasn't it 8th of
October okay of course it wasn't even
far away is it 1310 8th or which order
wait
all that
it's ten thirteen thirteen yeah that
makes sense
no nope sorry I got confused by read me
you guys comment there was 113 there in
that was eight why the [ __ ] did you guys
write 13 in the comments so it's eight
No
no wait the years redundant
it's got to be 10 8:30 okay
yeah this is pointless huh
yes we just got to keep trying and
denied
did I do it
start with you did we do that I don't
remember what we try
are you guys trolling me
oops
you can do this yeah we did this [ __ ]
what I have we not tried I'm so tired
take 30 years off yeah that makes sense
because they said their 30th anniversary
its 2013 so which one do I start with in
[Music]
1982-83 not wait 73
there's someone else right 83 1008 you
do let's try that
I want it yeah we got the revenge
of course it says 30th anniversary you
[ __ ] do the ball I'm blaming
everything wrong with me not getting
into sleep last night
just so we're clear okay now we got a
lot of stuff to play with we can make
explosive arrows really want to try that
and then we don't have that yet Christ
smoke bomb mmm that actually would have
been helpful in that mess the other time
I feel like explosives more fun I'll go
with that that's a pretty painting
that's a dead plane lip lip lip lip low
weight can also make yeah nice wait can
I also make no any more tape we got a
lot of stuff here it's gonna be a big
fight coming up
yeah I'm sorry I'm not reading super
chat I'm not seeing any either but I
don't want it to take away from the
gameplay but the people watching this
offline offline gang all right what time
is it
I can play 15 more minutes and I got a
workout
like they hell yeah impossible puzzle
guys
replace it here doesn't fall down
hey I assumed this is where you're
supposed to be thanks Ellie appreciate
it Ellie
nope we should do this
all right over it up great man I can't
wait to use that
and we're in where the skies are so blue
and my peepee is blue yes
too high or I'm too short too short gang
here whoa here's the hospital
[ __ ] me closer
the game is growing on me I think I
passed the acceptance the anger all the
stages of grief you know you can just
enjoy it for what it is
some man yeah it's the pen another pen
absolutely Wallace what's the better way
to go here should I jump down there
huh yep all right let's be careful
before we jump jumping through a wall
okay so Tyler time I need your leg day
[ __ ] leg day this is a problem how do
you guys get motivated for leg day when
it was really hot in UK I legit work out
and I own I do like day and I almost
faint because all the blood just goes to
my legs and it's so hot I'm just like
alright I go sleep now legit fall asleep
during a workout it's so bizarre it's
kind of comforting away it's not good
obviously feel like anything improve my
diet so this [ __ ] don't happen it's like
I understand why people skip leg day
because then it is what it is but I do
enjoy it too I think it would be boring
to just work out your Rockmore muscles
all the time variation makes it fun cuz
I don't mind I think is there because it
was so [ __ ] hot
and I had eaten like a big lunch - and
the blood blood goes to your digestion
that's right didn't attack me feel like
it's shotgun time here
I can see people liking this game if you
didn't play the first one there's no
expectations there's no disappointment
it just is what it is maybe that's why
he's getting so high rating apparently
IJ in Japan and IGN America rated the
scheme varied their friendly and japan's
criticism I don't know if it was real I
just read a translation it was so valid
like at least acknowledging its flaws
because when it shines it really shines
just great lacks a bit and I can't hear
them so they're gonna spook me I think
spook me spook me
I said spook don't cancel me these guys
really tough
I assume you can't hear these guys yep
Thank You Ellie
[Music]
semester fighter taking these guys out
what happens if I throw I don't want to
really try it but they definitely solve
me
I've got something in there and here -
there they go hey little girl don't come
near me and Diablo in the house I know
you're there
alright let's take it easy
I can random glares on the ground
alright this definitely more
I can't hear them though you just gotta
listen
that's definitely bound to be a gem
scare coming up
oh I'm look at this guy so cute oh
there's another one right there
oh god maybe good time to use the bombs
I place one here throw a bottle the hell
are you going
got your [ __ ] clever girl
there's one more in was that it damn you
guys blew up good ha ha I think that was
it check for their favor
Sweet Home Alabama yeah give me back my
bottle can't play without it sure hope
there's no more this is a bit spooky
looting in here but I want it what's
going on
Juan gang what does that mean
and this place is huge
yes I like these could go for our
silence actually you're like okay
there's definitely more
whoa
you know it's like that
mmm
I can't go there
without the hey
guess we're going downstream from here
all right I gotta go
better workout recording video what some
other stuff it's kind of want to keep
some ways
so that clicking sound means you can
crap something new oh this is creepy do
I go through the creepy corridor or
through the window I think I know which
one
[Music]
[Applause]
getting better at the hedgehogs mate all
right time to go literally saver time to
go time to go she said it all right got
to work out and have other stuff to do
today so early stream thanks for joining
our live stream very epic see you guys
tomorrow
El Diablo out how we're gonna do leg day
with our legs you don't skip leg day
that's just harder it is those are the
rules
[Music]
any other questions
have a great day guys I'll see you next
time alright bye bye thanks